14 seconds no way you can't keep up with
14 seconds on the clock it's going to be
decided
on the clock magnus may be winning on
the board but it's still a bit unclear
um but yeah eight seconds yeah this
is going to be all over too fast and too
strong magnus nelson
is he actually losing on time now he'll
do above yeah yeah three seconds
two seconds there we go he's gonna let
his clock run out two points down he's
losing on the board actually duboff but
the clock is the deciding factor wow and
mine is reacting instantly as the game
is over
with a win for magnus didi actually win
on on time there
he did win on time at the end but he
also has a winning position on the board
and a crazy day is over for these two
play it ends up with magnus carlsen
being the winner
of this quarter finals he will play the
semi-finals dunya dubois fought
so hard he'd had a fantastic day it's
just not enough
he uh he is knocked out he was the
winner of the quarterfinal in the air
things masters
magnus gets his revenge in this one yeah